it what you think well I feel fear about
this and therefore I shouldn't do it
it's normal to be to feel fair like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you shouldn't feel fair
if you dissect your fears if you name
them and study them they lose their
power sometimes fear comes from not
being prepared you know I mean if we go
back to sports if I'm going to a game
didn't watch tape didn't do any of this
stuff people are these scared want to be
happy
build a life not just the business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to conquer your fear
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one act despite fear with Elon Musk who
are unusually fearless and willing to go
in the face of other people telling you
something that's crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that well first
well I'd say I actually think I think I
feel feel fear quite strongly so it's
not as though I just have the absence of
fear I've I feel it quite strongly but
there are times when if something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do you do it in spite of the
fear so speaking of important things
like people shouldn't think III I should
if you should think well I feel fear
about this and therefore I shouldn't do
it it's normal to be to feel fair like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you shouldn't feel fair
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually we're
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so my starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving forward
so that were still do some good yeah
same with Tesla I thought your odds of a
car company succeeding were extremely
low rule number two do fear setting with
Tim Ferriss so when I was interviewing
Jamie Foxx for tools of titans I asked
him how he developed confidence in his
kids he's one of the most confident
human beings I've ever met and he said
whenever they were facing fear were
afraid of something stressed about
something he would say what's on the
other side of fear he would ask them
that and then he pause and he'd say
nothing nothing's on the other side of
your meaning that if you dissect your
fears if you name them and study them
they lose their power and the way I
translate that is with something called
fear setting in my own life rather than
goal setting that's fine but you can't
be driving around with the emergency
brake on so fear setting is very simple
I look at the I take a piece of paper I
divide it into three columns at the top
I put what I'm afraid of
and the decision whatever I think is
risky or scary first column all the
worst things that could happen in detail
the worst things that could happen
second column for each of those bullets
what I could do to minimize the
likelihood of them happening and then
last column for each bullet if they
happen how could I get back to where I
am now if you do this exercise what you
end up doing is completely disarming
your fears because you've made them very
very specific you've taken them from
hazy to extremely clear and that allows
you to take risks and do incredible
things simply because you've removed the
emergency brake also if you want to
learn how to have more confidence check
out my 254 series the link is free is in
the description below there are times
when if something is important enough
you believe it enough that you do you do
it in spite of fear if you are trying to
make high-level decisions focus on
time-consuming high priority projects
rule number three pack fear with Trent
Shelton how I develop a mindset a belief
that my purpose is something that I
should go all-in on I think one thing
that you can do okay I think fear is a
part of that right like fear like you
might not go all-in because you're
fearful of like you say you might not
you know be as great as someone else or
you might not you know succeed in that
field so for one understanding what fear
is which for me it's it's basically just
creating a normal result from a
situation you haven't experienced yet so
you're telling yourself what is going to
be before you ever go to do you're ever
gonna do it so of course you're not
gonna go do it you know so if you
believe this result is gonna happen it's
gonna be bad exactly I'm gonna fail I'm
gonna look stupid everyone's gonna make
fun of me then you're probably not gonna
want to do it exactly or be able to give
your food like it's like playing
football like you go out there and like
we're gonna lose our
terrible game more likely you have a
terrible game it's gonna be hard to
operate a high level so I've just
learned to I always say like if fear was
a door and behind this door was all this
negativity things that I'm saying like
I'm gonna lose I'm gonna suck I'm never
gonna walk through that door so in order
for me to walk through the door even
though the door is super scary I have to
make empowering things on this side of
the door right I'm gonna learn I'm gonna
grow even if I don't win it's gonna be
some valuable in it so let me walk
through this door right even though it
might not be perfect I'm still gonna
find growth inside of it so to me that's
like a small little trick to like really
hack fear and get over fear and also of
course it's Brendan talked about this a
lot like not just repetition but like
really like focus repetition like fun in
the area and say you know what I'm gonna
get better at this because sometimes
fear comes from not being prepared you
know I mean if we go back to sports if
I'm going to a game didn't watch tape
then do any of this stuff I'm people
ready scared or taking the test you know
so preparation also is a is a part of
that and so I would just tell people you
got it you got to figure out all that
how to get over fear but just go out
there and do it and one way to go out
there and do it
I use leverage questions with myself so
I'll go all out bro like this might be
over-the-top stuff but say so I was
running running it was a saddle next to
running I don't know what the trail was
my friend took me on like a back trail
and as I'm running you know it sucks
it's uphill my heart rate is like zone
five and I just tell myself like if I
quit on this then I'm not living it for
rehabbers if I quit
then I'm putting the monster than myself
that's a quitter and my son and my
daughter are gonna feel that like I go
over the top with it so I don't give up
and so what leverage questions it can be
anything I can be the simple levers
question that tomorrow's not promised
that's one of the best ones right
150,000 people die every day tomorrow's
not promised so if I'm not going after
it then I'm gonna die incomplete I'm
gonna die being a person that I wasn't
created to be like I want to meet the
greatest me I want to meet my full
potential so I I told hub Tom this
yesterday about I would literally go to
cemeteries at one point
this seems super creepy like I'm weird
but I will go to cemeteries after my
friend committed suicide death became so
surreal to me because it was somebody
that was like next to me I will go to
cemeteries sometimes with my friend just
walk around and be like bro we're gonna
be here one day Wow and it's like you
look at the tombstones you realize that
deaf have no preference you know
different ages it's five year olds or 80
year olds it's black it's white it's
women it's men its children its adults
and it just made it super surreal for me
so gang leverage right in your life like
what's something that's gonna make you
move that's all you have to do is move
take that first step that's the most
important step in the journey and listen
you're gonna fall in your place you're
gonna be embarrassed but everybody who's
experienced greatness has been through
that and rule number four the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
unlock your brain with John Assaraf when
you recognize a fear I want you to do
this it's called inner sighs number one
it's called take six calm the circuits
when fear neuro chemicals are released
in your brain you've activated the fear
or stress response center in the brain
when you just observe the emotion called
fear through being quiet and breathing
six times in through your nose and out
through your mouth like this you take a
deep breath in for five seconds
[Music]
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw and if you do this five
seconds in five seconds out five seconds
in five seconds out with six to ten
breaths
you're gonna deactivate the fear
response Center and that actually is
gonna reactivate your thinking center in
your brain so that you can move on to
inner sighs number two inner sighs
number one is take six calm the circuits
inner sighs number two is called aya a I
a and that stands for awareness
intention action so here's how you do
this after you do the first inner sighs
then you move to inner sighs number two
and then you ask yourself in a calm
relaxed state what am I thinking right
now what am I feeling right now
am i calm or am i tense am i breathing
deeply or shallow is my heart beat fast
or slow and in this state of calm
awareness as you deactivate the brains
fear or stress response you can observe
what you are feeling and what you are
thinking and what you were doing and
then you can ask self the next question
that is the I what is my intention right
now is my intention to move forward or
is my intention to stay in this fearful
state and chances are you gonna say well
I really want to move forward and then
yourself what
one action step that I can take to move
forward towards my goal and dream so
this is how it works after you do the
inner size number one to calm the
circuits and to deactivate the reactive
state that fear causes and then you move
into the second inner size called aya to
move it to the responsive state
awareness intention action now puts you
in control of being aware of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking and then being at choice of
what you want to do so when you combine
these two inner sizes you are now
reconfiguring the neural network in your
brain around the goal that you want to
achieve and instead of allowing the real
or imagined danger to control you to
stop you dead in your tracks you take
one action step in a calm state and that
rewires your brain so that the same
reaction doesn't hold you back anymore
and that you are now able to use fear as
your fuel for success now I've got a
special bonus clip with Jason Silva and
Lois house on how to appreciate the
moment that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to act despite fear
number two how can you apply Tim Ferriss
asphere setting exercise and number
three what would you do to hack your
fear today what do you think holds us
all back the most what's the thing that
holds us back from our greatness
fear what fear failure fear of success
fear of the judgement of other people
well I think all those fears are rooted
in the fear of death and there's a
theory it's called terror management
theory and it comes from Ernest Becker's
work in the denial of death but these
psychologists have done these studies
basically say that if you remind people
of their mortality even subliminally
tend to become more judgmental of the
other more sort of hostile towards
people who are different than them when
you in live people of their more time
yeah and that's why politicians populist
politicians like the man we have in
office he uses fear to get people to
hate the other the immigrants are that
this and that and and it's like this he
keeps using these words like it's
dangerous they're coming after us it's a
threat because you remind people of
their mortality what makes people recoil
and become like more people are afraid
to towards the other eye then they're
gonna vote in a different and they're
even they're not even thinking mortality
just a threat any kind of threat but
isn't the is it the country or the
culture of Bhutan is that what it is
yeah every five times a day they focus
on their death they they pray and
acknowledge their death and in that
thought process five times they make
their six a happiest country or culture
you know world because they're always
focused on like being present and being
joyful but we have because one day
that's what oh well I guess it's they've
acquiesced to that reality it's it's
acceptance there's something they're not
as clinging and by not clinging they
suffer less there's an app called we
croak god it's called we croak I think
it's called yeah w/e croak like the like
you frog yeah and it texted me five
times a day you're gonna die with a
quote of like being in the now text you
five times a day
he's like I'm notification on my phone
it comes up that's all does five times
it says you know that might you were
gonna die I know if I want to sign up
for that and it's you should try for a
week it's just experiment and just ally
ourselves to say okay let me be it
allows you to say none of this is gonna
matter one day
if you want five strategies to destroy
your fear for good check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I'm not the best like if something bad
happens tomorrow I would default into
thinking well I'm so grateful that I've
had it for this long yeah